[Music]
how does the news shape the way we see
the world here's the world based on the
way it looks based on land mass and
here's how new shapes what Americans see
this map
this map shows the number of seconds
that American network in cable news
organizations dedicated to news stories
by country in February of 2007 just one
year ago now this was a month when North
Korea agreed to dismantle its nuclear
facilities there was massive flooding in
Indonesia and in Paris
the IPCC released its study confirming
man's impact on global warming the u.s.
accounted for 79 percent of total news
coverage and when we take out the US and
look at the remaining 21 percent we see
a lot of Iraq that's that big green
thing there and little else the combined
coverage of Russia China and India for
example reached just 1% when we analyzed
all the news stories and removed just
one story here's how the world looked
what was that story the death of Anna
Nicole Smith this story eclipsed every
country except Iraq and received 10
times the coverage of the IPCC report
and this cycle continues as we all know
Britney has loomed pretty large lately
so why don't we hear more about the
world one reason is that news networks
have reduced the number of their foreign
bureaus by half aside from one person
ABC mini bureaus in Nairobi New Delhi
and Mumbai there are no network news
bureaus in all of Africa India or South
America places that are home to more
than 2 billion people the reality is is
that covering Britney is cheaper and
this lack of global coverage is all the
more disturbing when we see where people
go for news local TV news looms large
unfortunately only dedicates 12% of its
coverage to international news and what
about the web the most popular news
sites don't do much better last year pew
and the Columbia j-school analyzed the
14,000 stories that appeared on Google
News is front-page and they in fact
covered the same 24 news events
similarly a study and eat content showed
that much of global news from US news
creators is recycled stories from the AP
wire services and Reuters and don't put
things into a context that people can
understand their connection to it so if
you put it all together this could help
explain why today's college graduates as
well as less educated Americans know
less about the world than their
counterparts did 20 years ago and if you
think that it's simply because we are
not interested you would be wrong in
recent years Americans who say they
closely follow global news most of the
time grew to over 50% the real question
is this distorted worldview what we want
for Americans in our increasingly
interconnected world I know we can do
better and can we afford not to thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you